autre grand perdant de ce dimanche
le modem de françois bayrou on est bien
loin des 18 % de la présidentielle le
nouveau parti centriste n'obtiendra
qu'un à quatre députés véronique saint
olive linda saadi
françois bayrou a perdu son pari le
modem n'obtient que 7 7% des voix
même pas la moitié du score obtenu par
le candidat centriste aux
présidentielles
en clair quatre députés au maximum
dimanche prochain françois bayrou est
lui-même en ballottage favorable dans sa
circonscription des pyrénées-atlantiques
mais son parti est engloutie par labatt
bleue il ne lui reste plus qu'à tenter
de faire bonne figure
quand on évoque une mort politique
programmée
c'est au contraire le débile et
commençons le commencement de la vie
d'un centre indépendant en france le
respect dans là ça se fait dans chaque
saas fee dans le courage mais c'est
précisément le point de départ anne
marie comparini députée sortante
illustre cette défaite l'ancien
président de région incarnait le centre
qui gagne mais est éliminé hier soir
elle faire une circonscription
symbolique la seule co détenait le modem
dans le rhône elle demeure pourtant
fidèle au discours de françois bayrou
les français ne doit pas craindre de
vouloir le flux rallye c'est à dire une
assemblée miroir fidèle de tous les
français
al'inverse les députés udf qui ont
quitté françois bayrou pour rallier
nicolas sarkozy décroche la timbale avec
leur nouveau centre comme hervé morin
ministre de la défense réélu au premier
tour dans leur donc 50,05 scor définis
comme de nuit marielle de sarnez le bras
droit françois bayrou a quant à elle été
éliminée à paris mais lot de consolation
elle pèse sur le second tour
ce soir elle indique qu'elle ne donnera
pas de consigne de vote mais elle
revendique la défense du pluralisme
c'est un clin d'oeil à gauche